So there’s this fantastic Wikipedia list
descriptively titled “Wikipedia-colon-unusual-articles.
” I just remember it as “That Wikipedia
List.”
It’s a collection of hundreds of articles
about unusual, unexpected, and unbelievable
subjects.
No matter what link you click, its bound to
be interesting.
For that reason, every week I’m going to
click on a new link and teach you a little
more about our amazing world.
With that, let’s find this week’s article.
So, US Presidents are four times more likely
to be left handed than the general public.
On average, about 10% of individuals are left-handed,
while 46% of Presidents since 1923 were left-handed.
Why do we only look at the President’s since
1923?
Well, before recently, left-handedness was
treated like a disease.
Believe it or not, the bible included tons
of anti-lefty rhetoric, so parents and teachers
would often punish kids for using their left-hand.
Therefore, most people, including presidents,
would use their right hand to write even if
they were born a leftie.
It’s entirely possible that many early presidents
were left-handed, but it’s just not known
since by the time things were written about
them, they were already using their right
hands for everything.
Herbert Hoover was the first President that
we know was right handed and since his presidency,
Truman, Ford, Reagan, Bush Senior, Clinton,
and Obama have been added to that not-so-elusive
club.
So what’s behind this statistical anomaly?
Well for one Americans and other westerners
are more likely to be left-handed than our
brethren in the eastern hemisphere.
There’s a continuing social pressure in
many Asian countries to use the right-hand
so many left-handed children are taught to
switch.
There’s no longer that pressure in the US,
so about 12% of Americans are left-handed.
Men are also slightly more likely to be left-handed,
so since approximately 100% of US Presidents
have been males, this elevates the chance
of a left handed president by a little bit.
What most contributes to this phenomenon is
that Presidents are generally considered to
be smart people.
The average iq of the general public is about
100, while the average estimated iq of presidents
is around 130.
It’s really hard to determine if left handedness
is linked to increased intelligence, but Mensa
reports that 20% of its members are left handed.
That means that if you’re left handed, you’re
twice as likely to have an iq over 130, or
at least to be a member of Mensa.
What is indisputable, however, is that left-handed
kids have to learn to adapt to a world made
for right handed people.
Scissors, can openers, desks, doors, roads,
and even the english writing system were made
for right handed people.
Michael Peters, a neuropsychologist at the
University of Guelph, said that his research
has shown that this necessity for adaptation
leads to left-handed individuals being “slightly
more resistant to social pressures,” and
gives them “an independent streak.”
These are traits that most agree are useful
for leaders.
Chris McManus of University College London
wrote in Scientific America that “left-handers’
brains are structured differently from right-handers’
in ways that can allow them to process language,
spatial relations and emotions in more diverse
and potentially creative ways.”
In the past couple decades, three of the five
general elections have been exclusively between
left-handed candidates.
So are the candidates overwhelmingly left-handed
in the 2016 election?
Nope.
In fact, no remaining presidential candidate
is left-handed.
Is this a sign of what’s to come?
Well we’ll just have to wait and see.